bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i am super
excited for this conversation i've got
oriole here how are you doing sir
bang bang boom great to be here
absolutely where where are you right now
i am right now
in the heart of tel aviv the country
that vaccinates
people faster than you can say it
i love it all right let's uh remind
people what your background is and kind
of what you guys do at zen go and we're
going to get into this uh bitcoin and
crypto
uh explainer kind of introduction uh
episode
uh so uriel ceo of xango
uh been in tech for way too long
on both sides of the aisle both
entrepreneur and an investor
but now as an entrepreneur and building
xango for the past two years
which is uh an easy crypto wallet for
people to invest in the space
and sort of all-in-one mobile wallet
where you can
um send receive buy sell and spend
cryptocurrencies very easy
i love it uh so let's just for all these
people who are coming in now they see
bitcoin's price
ripping right they're like oh my god
this is amazing i need to go learn about
it
uh let's just start with kind of 101
like what is a cryptocurrency
well it's a it's a digital asset that
can be
uh um that is rare uh and that is rare
and therefore that has
uh value when the rarity of of this
asset is mathematically proven it's not
because people say it is rare
uh it's because it you can actually
verify it
now the the the beauty of it is that
unlike money you cannot unlimited
without limits
print i print it and therefore
when when you want to know exactly
what's happening with the transaction
everything can be proven you know where
it's coming from you know where it's
going to
and the quantity also is is limited so
for people who are coming from the world
where they all they know about is money
it's really difficult to understand at
first because you don't understand this
notion of
unlimited money but here is the thing in
2020
we have learned that there is something
like unlimited money
and covet crisis has helped us realize
that we've seen these trillions of
dollars being
literally printed by the fed in the u.s
in many
you know central banks in the world to
sustain the economy so people start to
realize
that the money that they have in their
pocket does not have necessarily the
value that they thought that they had
and so that has attracted them just out
of curiosity
towards these uh digital currencies that
are
that cannot be printed at will and so i
think this is the first point that um
needs to be understand
understood about cryptocurrencies i know
this is also near and dear to your heart
based on what i heard on audio podcast
and i think this is something that needs
to be understand
understood when you get started
absolutely
we'll talk through a little bit about uh
that's cryptocurrencies then talk about
kind of
how people can get started with
cryptocurrencies
yeah so to get started first i think you
need to understand
uh a few things that are very different
from the
the world of money as we know it's first
it's a 24
7 world it never stops it's really the
money money that never sleeps as they
say
and we are not used to that our banks
are closing down on the weekend the
stock market is shutting down
during the weekend there are like
post-trading hours in crypto and like
you know we all know it we don't sleep
so much
it's like it's never stops and so you
need to be ready for that you need to
to be ready for a pace of continuous
activity the second thing that you need
to be aware of
is that in uh and my we might talk about
it more later is
in in the world of crypto you need to be
very careful with security
and i know unlike traditional finance
where you have
an account where you can reset reset a
password
or you can like press a button called
you know i lost my password
call your bank to get your account reset
in crypto if you lose
uh your password which is basically a
private key but i will call it a
password to make it simple
then you lose all your funds and we've
seen 2020 many of those stories
been horrible recently there was a story
in the new york times where someone lost
you know
nearly 200 or more than 200 million
dollars so
being careful with security is super
important and here is the thing
people will make mistakes because no
matter how careful they are they are not
used to deal with security
especially with security related to
money
so being very careful in the solution
that you use understanding them
is super super important whatever
solutions you pick
make sure you understand it fully and
especially the limits of it
especially the risk associated to it and
there are risk to
every single solution there is no magic
bullet
there is not a a gold standard if i may
say
in crypto security even what was
considered until recently the safest
solution
uh hardware wallets we've seen it with
ledger there
are point of failures there are security
things that can happen to your funds
you can be uh you can be phished
your credentials can be lost um etc etc
so you need to be
understanding very well the risks and um
and by the way this is what we we've
tried to build at xango which is a
a system uh a wallet it does not depend
on password it's actually the first
whatever that does the dependent
password so that that's really something
very very important understanding the
limit of
of the system that you are using the
i don't know if you want to say
something here but i think it's really
an important point
how does a wall work without passwords
so
uh this is this is where the the magic
of you know multi-party computation
uh can enter uh multi-party computation
has been a crypto
science in cryptography that's been
around for 30 years but basically
what you're doing with multi-party
computation is you are
you are distributing the security of a
single secret in that case of a private
key
among multiple parties and what we have
built in xango
is is a completely passwordless system
around that where
we ask you multiple factors one of which
is going to be
your uh your biometrics not the device
biometrics
but the liveness biometrics i could show
you right now i have a 3d mask behind me
and even those don't work but basically
what it does it's biometric scan of your
face and it looks if you are alive if
you are you
and so only you can access your account
you can associate
a trusted face to your account also so
that someone that you trust can also
help you recover something
changes in your face but what happens is
you just getting with an email
you're getting with a magic link like on
slack and you get in with your biometric
scan and your account is fully set up in
19 seconds no password to remember
nothing nothing can happen if you forget
something because there's nothing to
forget
and so for beginners it's very very
important and we've seen recently
an explosion of traffic in our system
because of this recent bull run of
people coming to crypto
and they need something that is at the
same time simple but also that feels
secure
and when you expose them to all those
private keys and 24 words
it's very intimidating we are in crypto
for a few years we are used to that
but most people are are not used to deal
with that and it's a very intimidating
even sometimes frightening uh step to go
to and
most of the time actually it's been even
a break for most people to get in
because they don't know what to do with
that
so security really matters understanding
it
if you want to go you need to understand
the limit of it and then when
when you go you go so you get in you
understand your you understand
that you you have your wallets now and
you can go
get some crypto the most people think
that the only way to
get bitcoin or to get crypto is to
actually purchase it
but this is only one of the ways there
are many many ways you can
obtain crypto or bitcoin without even
purchasing it
there are many referral programs that
enable you to invite friends and earn
crypto
there are many cashback programs where
you can just spend real money and embark
on crypto
there are many airdrops that are
distributing crypto for free without you
doing
anything there are ways you can get paid
uh your salary in crypto uh and it's
happening more and more as you
uh as you were aware you can uh we for
example
pay many freelancers in cryptocurrencies
and they want that
and so why they want that it's a
different reason but it's happening it's
way convenient
more convenient that sending a bank wire
when they are on the other side of the
world
so so getting paid in crypto is another
way and so there are many ways now
if you want to purchase you can purchase
and there are many many avenues for
doing that
exchanges you can go to many many
exchanges so you have to go through
a registration process an approval
process a kyc process the way they will
ask you
identification it's surprising the first
time but then you get used to it
and then you will be able to buy with a
credit card with a bank wire
and then you have to know what you're
doing you have to know when you're
buying of course
and here no financial advice i think
there's a disclosure in your podcast
but you have to find out what is the
best moment for you to get in
the important point is to make sure that
once you make the purchase
you invest money that you're not ready
to lose that you are
sorry that you are ready to lose and you
will feel okay about it if that happens
because there are risk
risk of volatility there are risk of
things that can go to zero even though
the probability is
low and when you make a first purchase
and you see those
prices go up and down it's very easy to
panic
it's very easy to not understand that
and that's something that people
that are new to crypto are also not used
to this volatility
factor uh you know the stock market when
it moves like
three percent four percent up or down
you know people are kind of
again okay all right that's kind of you
know that's the day
but in crypto for example today it has
moved like nearly 10 percent
you say what the hell is going on or a
few days ago when bitcoin lost 24
in a day well if you've been long enough
you know that's part of the game
that's how it works and so once you know
that
it's fine but the first time you need to
be ready for it so
if someone wants to get into crypto try
to
actually not do it alone that's some
that's a so
often a tip that we give to people who
want to get started
try to not do that alone so that people
can actually
reassure you when you do something and
uh you know
very important like all the crypto
services good crypto services have great
customer support
so that they can assist people in those
moment of tension
of stress so being aware of the
volatility
is super important that tell you that
you don't panic and you don't panic sell
and this is the best way to lose to lose
money
so once you know that then there is
your first transaction like that's it
you got your crypto
and you're going to make your first
transaction here is a damn stressful
moment i don't know if you remember pomp
the first time you made your first time
transaction on the blockchain
you had to take a public address oh my
god
what is this thing like looks like
nothing you have to send it you have to
verify it
three times four times you compare your
screenshot with the computer
because this looks like nothing and this
is awful this is damn awful i'm sure at
some point those will be resolved
but today this is the case so you have
to be familiar
with a public key and no panic there you
just have to
look at the address that you're using
and make sure that you are indeed
sending to that address then you have to
be aware that
blockchain transactions are not instant
okay sure there is the lightning network
and there is all these like layer two
but when you are beginner you're going
to make
a normal transaction you're not going to
go through those phone key services
that are unbattled tested and not built
at scale so you're going to make a
normal transaction
a normal transaction is not instant and
then there is this concept of
confirmations so people are not familiar
with confirmation when you make a
paypal wire or a venmo wire or a bank
wire you just press the send button
and it arrives or it doesn't there is
not this notion of like
i have to wait for this transaction to
be panning
and confirmed once and confirmed twice
and so
understanding the concept of
confirmation meaning that behind the
scene
there is a process of confirmation
operated by a network of miners or
computers
or a security process is important so
that you don't panic that you've pressed
the button sell
and you don't see the transaction
arriving it takes sometimes
this time can actually widely vary can
take a few minutes it can take sometimes
a few days when the network is congested
and then you have this confirmation that
you can see so you know most of the
wallets they will
make you uh understand that there is a
confirmation and which number
uh some of the best will actually notify
you when the transaction is actually
confirmed
but understanding this concept of
confirmation is important so that's it
you've you got on your wallet you got on
your first crypto
you made it you made your first
transaction you understood
what is a an address and a public key so
you can send your your crypto
you understand what is the concept of uh
of confirmation you understand that
crypto
is not uh instant and that it can take
some time but now
there is a new thing that you need to
understand is the concept of
fee transaction fee right that's
something that is
a deep source of frustration in the
industry for new beginners
why because we are we are kind of not
used also to that like when you
sure bank have used uh have used a
custom does to
pay fees or for all sorts of things and
we kind of forgot about it but
people come to crypto with like the
dream of this new finance
paradigm where everything is fast and
going to be cheaper or free
well no guess what you have to pay fees
so what kind of fees do you have to pay
you have to pay network fees
and those network fees can widely vary
you have to pay the miners
okay they don't need to understand that
they have to pay the miners who operate
the transaction and so
uh so those fees can widely vary if the
network is very congested
it can be a few cents and it can be
single digit dollars and sometimes
double digit dollars
like we've seen bitcoin network fees or
ethereum network fees
uh being so expensive that sometimes
they are more expensive than the total
amount of money that you want to send
and if you are using got four bit a
smart contract
like for example lending money on
compound
for you know for for getting some apr
or something else then that can quickly
rise up to tens of dollars
so it's very very surprising and hard to
understand
and it's even worse to understand if you
want to try to get into the website that
explain it
they all look very geeky and there are
sort of graphs
and you don't understand that the point
is
if you don't if you're not aware that
there are fees if you're not aware that
they are highly volatile
if you're not aware that those can vary
over time
it can be a deep point of frustration
most people discover it sometimes
too late we at xango for example spend
an enormous amount of time to explain to
people how this works
in our customer support sometimes it's
enough but many don't
don't feel sometimes they feel that we
deceive them although it's not
our responsibility and i'm sure most
services have the same issue
that's something that is built by design
the worse is on ethereum
because you have to sometimes when you
want to send a near c20 token a token
you have to pay the gas in ethereum and
if you don't have it then you
you're stuck and so it's kind of great
getting into limbo where you just
acquired a great
token or whatever chain link you need to
swap token whatever
yeah that's it i got it i went through
all those steps and now you want to send
it and say oh you have to stop here
you have to get now some ethereum
because this is how you send a
transaction
so the concept of fee is deeply
frustrating in industry
not just because it exists because it is
complex in itself
and one of the jobs of the wallets are
there is to make sure that you smooth
that as much as possible you cannot
eliminate it
you cannot pay for it if you pay for it
you will go bankrupt
some have tried to do it and they deeply
regretted it
and went backwards so so you just need
to make sure that people understand it
as much as possible so now you
understand all those these things
and i think at the end of the day now
you're part of the
beginners of the digital economy right
now you understand that
you are in charge of your own funds that
you can make transactions
that you there are multiple ways that
you can acquire crypto or you can earn
crypto
and that now you can spend crypto
and now there is a new chapter which is
investing
these assets in all sorts of services
but then when you realize that you are
at the step you're not a beginner
anymore
you start to become an advanced user and
you start to explore the avenues of the
of the crypto economy and the new open
finance
so anyway i think those are very very
important things
we tend to forget them because we've
been so much into it
that uh once we you know we do it
naturally it's like a new grammar or new
language that you've learned right you
forget the alphabet
and the grammar or when you play music
you forget the scale you just play
but when you deal with beginners and i'm
sure in the
recent run many people have tried to
contact you or
ask you questions i got like i got
harassed
by so many people what is this and what
is that and and
just a good reminder that to be down to
us
that the majority of the world have no
idea what we're talking about
absolutely no idea and we need to be
very very
uh humble in the way that we help those
people get to this industry we have to
be patient
and we have to be very very simple in
the way we explain things because it's
very intimidating
so i think that's a good uh a good uh
first uh let's say a first package of
of of tips for people who want to get
started
and uh you know if you have grandmothers
or if you have aunts or if you have
your friends and family who want to get
started in crypto they should be aware
about
all of those things that's a great
primer why are so many institutions and
corporations getting into it
well because they they also realized the
same thing
uh you know they realized that you know
if you look at the value of the dollar
and it's really relative weight and
power for the past
uh two years and we will we will not say
who is responsible for it or not
okay uh uh but there was a global crisis
recently that has accelerated that
you see that the the dollar has
basically
lost his uh momentum uh
as a of an asset of trade
and a set of value and so there are so
many things that
are depending on the dollar uh including
all the global uh financial
infrastructure so
all the institutional players who
are exposed to these mechanisms
say to themselves well what am i doing
here
i see my you know all my assets
basically melting
i cannot let that happen i need to have
something that is
uncorrelated to the value of that dollar
and that works by a different kind of
logic
and they see this kind of new asset in
particular bitcoin
uh that cannot be printed that will that
accrues in value the more people
participate in the network
and suddenly uh and suddenly the the
they make just a simple calculation
maybe i should diversify
my portfolio and what has happened in
the past six months you've seen
public companies putting crypto in their
balance sheet
you've seen uh fortune 500 companies
uh starting to talk very differently
about bitcoin in a very positive manner
banks you start to see those fortunes
and and billionaires also
even people like mark cuban that are
very negative about about crypto
basically you realize that they own some
of it and so you have kind of this wave
you have also all these celebrities that
wonder themselves publicly if they
should
expose to bitcoin get exposed to bitcoin
and do right and so you have kind of
this wave
of people that start to adopt it and
that's kind of
engaging more people to think about it
not to take action but to think about it
and so you have the you know the the
relative perception
that the dollar is losing its value that
it is
need to have an edge an exposure to your
portfolio you start to have all these
public companies
that start to make you know
microstrategy of course and everyone's
talking about them all the time
okay they could they could make a
podcast right of their
of what they're doing on a daily basis
it's it's just insane they've made the
took a position of a billion dollar i
think
in cryptocurrencies uh you know very
very very smart guy behind it
and so there is not one company right
now in the world that is not
having second thoughts about it that is
not discussing their
bitcoin strategy uh um you know
it would be irresponsible for them to
ignore it it doesn't mean that they will
take action
but it's definitely on the table and so
on top of that you have also the retail
market and
it's not a u.s trend it's not
a just a western development it's it's a
global trend
everywhere in the world you see this
kind of mass attraction
for something that enables what i like
to call a borderless economy
meaning a system where you can transact
freely with
anyone without permission of anyone so
you can
not just speculate but also participate
into
all the financial functions of an
economy the most important one is
getting paid
there are so many people that are not
being able are not
cannot get paid because they don't have
access to a bank account or their bank
account
or or the bank account has been has been
closed or because
their rates are not functioning well or
because the national currencies
is worth nothing and so we have to
remember that we are very lucky in
developed countries but there is an
enormous amount of
actually the majority of the world with
who is not so lucky
and so they need something that works
and for them it's not like a nice to
have or an
edge it's an urgent need it's something
that they need
yesterday and so we see this adoption
at the global scale of all those
all those people who want to just have
an access to an asset that they can
transact with very simply
uh and obviously they most of the time
have only a mobile phone so
they can use only a mobile wallet they
cannot use a hardware wallet or
a computer wallet and they don't have
the sophisticated vaults of
the edge funds and things of that nature
and
uh the first thing that they want
usually is bitcoin so
so there was kind of this bull run that
has happened recently
has been also illustrated by that and
you know many companies
including us i've seen our traffic
exploded
you know i think the price of bitcoin
went 3x in uh
in two or three months something like
that or close to 3x
well all the servers went also 3x all
the matrix went 3x
and all our sleep has been decreased by
3x2
and everyone has had down times and it's
been really a challenge for this
industry
uh just proving that we are not yet
ready for mainstream it is happening but
we're not yet ready
uh the customer support you know and
coinbase for example just
published an apology they can't keep up
it's really really hard
when you have all those people coming
with all the points that we've mentioned
have
no clue what crypto is about and ask
this question are
impatient and don't understand security
and etc etc etc
it's very hard to keep up with that
demand not to serve them
uh the crypto that they want but also to
serve them
as customers because they have
legitimate questions so it's an industry
that is i think in an inflection point
in terms of the nature of the demand
that is shaping it it's no longer you
know
early believers geeks financial traders
those who have made crypto the 10 first
first 10 years we see now
two different shapes adding up on top of
that compounding on that industry
which are clearly institutions and not
crypto institutions institutions who
have
understood the necessity to diversify
and need an edge of exposure in their
portfolio
and this massive retail demand uh that
is global
and not just in western development
because they just need exposure to
something that enables them to
live and participate and build their
wealth because otherwise they have
nothing or close to nothing
so i think this what we've seen in the
past months and that
has been really exciting but also very
challenging
what are you looking most forward to in
2021 like
what's the milestone you're most
interested in well
you know it's a very special day we were
recording on a very very special day to
date
there's a new president in the u.s and
there is a lot of eyes
that are turned towards what's going to
be done in terms of
uh first regulation there is a set of
actions that have been engaged before
the
nomination of uh of president biden uh
that raised many questions about what
would happen to
uh to the space in terms of like how
would stable coin be considered
uh how will exchange relief to operate
with
with wallets um the identification of
the users the data that they need to
keep trace of
all these were kept in the air and
did never translated into any sort of
action but they have deep deep deep
consequences into our industry will be
shaped
organized and adopted by the outside
meaning the customers the users
and so now i guess one of the things
that everyone is waiting
is to see how this is going to play out
there is now a new
sec or chairman that has been nominated
uh which apparently i say apparently but
to be verified like in crypto is crypto
friendly
but we'll have to see uh we'll have to
see how the occ now also
is getting organized uh after brian
brooks now has departed and was
we all know it's very uh um looking
forward to the development of crypto
and so for me 2021 is a milestone here
in terms of
how the regulation in the u.s which
going to be a model for the rest of the
world
are going to be shaped there is a set of
critical
sec actions uh that are going to play
out in 2021
which could be uh defining to how some
projects are going to be evaluated
so the first one in mind is obviously
xrp because
we know that it's you know it's
happening right now so we'll see how it
plays out and
you know the the jury's out there but
uh i'm pretty certain that it's not the
last
there will be other type of action of
that nature
against other projects against other
tokens
and they will be defining we've seen
that they've hit big projects before
like telegram
that could not go out live because it
was stopped
i would say at the last minute um and
the sec seem to be
determined to to draw a line
it's not very clear what it is but to
draw one line and so
i'm also looking forward to see where
this how far this is going to go
finally i'm also very interested to see
how
finally because this is a choke point of
the industry
banks are finally going to adapt to that
new world
because uh i mean just to give you an
order of magnitude about
half maybe more of all crypto
transactions
purchases are censored by banks right
now
just because they decided so okay it's
not because it's illegal
it's not because they uh it is a new law
somewhere that says that is they decided
that it was
a danger for their customers and they
apply it randomly
and it's a real pain for customers for
crypto operators
for customer support etc etc they have
no reason to do it
even worse now there are there are texts
in the u.s in particular that allow
banks to
custody digital assets there are new
rules especially
instead of wyoming that allow peop
you can get a bank license if you're a
crypto company
and there is more more grants for
welcoming crypto
if you are a bank embracing the change
versus resisting to it it's like
being a newspaper in the early days of
the web and just
denying that you want to go digital well
that has turned really really really bad
for
some of them and really really well for
those who adapted so
i really want to see into 2021 banks
be braver be braver embrace the change
i'm sure
i'm ready to bet that there will be one
major back
that will make the the the move and it
will be a major win for them
because they will attract the industry
to them
and they will attract the adapters to
them and it it will set it will set the
pace for the rest of the industry
but unfortunately for now there is this
reality so
i i really want to see that change and
what i think what could could make
that change is also what i said before
the the regulation
uh on the rest on the technology i'm
pretty bullish i'm sure there will be
major innovation especially in the
territory of
fee management which is like i said
before
still an area of disasters and
frustration
for everyone in the space there is great
great progress in layer two
and in lightning network and i'm sure
we'll see something coming out tonight
so
overall i think uh there are a lot of
very important
uh milestone events that could be that
will be defining to
the adoption curve of uh of uh of the
industry
obviously more and more easy solutions
for people to use
not just for beginners but also just for
people like us who are very busy
and need something very convenient and
uh
i cannot say it enough people
underestimate the power of simplicity
and convenience
those have been unlockers for the
digital music business
for the streaming business for the
mobile business it will be an unlocker
also
for the crypto economy and right now the
space is still way
way too complicated even for the the
successful companies
last hope is i hope our world become a
little less centralized
right now the majority of crypto assets
and crypto
transactions are essentially done in
centralized services
which is precisely the opposite of what
crypto is supposed to be about
it's supposed to be a decentralized user
controlled
ecosystem and today it's not the case
and and the reason is precisely because
it's way easier to do it
in an exchange that to do it on a
decentralized wallet but i think
it's already changing we see the trend
of bitcoin moving out of exchanges back
to wallets
and i think he's going to accelerate in
2021
i think that's a great view on the world
where can we send people to find out
more about zengo
well it's very simple it's xango.com
and on twitter it's at xango no
no funky stuff we managed to get uh we
managed to get both
and uh and on twitter i'm easy to find i
usually
answer to all your tweets so you just
you just follow pump and you will find
me somewhere there
you're doing a fantastic job i love it
uh one last question for you you've
already answered all the uh the rapid
fire questions i normally do
so uh the only other question you've
never answered is uh what's your sleep
routine
i've got uh the guys that ate sleep now
are basically try to take over
the entire tech industry and get
everyone to use their thermo
thermoregulation mattresses
and i've got one and i'm sleeping like a
baby what's your sleep routine
my sleep routine is that simple i i turn
on the tv
i've got a bl i've got uh a backlog of
great uh tv shows that i'm uh i'm
watching the last one that i saw was
dead lasso which i highly recommend and
uh usually i fell asleep in 10 minutes
it works like it works perfect i love it
i love it
all right let's send people to uh
zengo.com or at zengo on twitter oreo
listen thank you so much for this is
fantastic you're an absolute wealth of
knowledge
i think that people who are coming into
the industry i can learn a ton from you
so i appreciate you taking the time
today to uh to do this
thank you my pleasure